eine farblose flüssigkeit abgefüllt den
zerbrechlichen ampullen und ein
versprechen cupid 19 kann besichtigt
werden
doch weil der impfstoff knapp ist
bekommt zuerst eine spritze wer
besonders gefährdet ist
zuerst die pflegeeinrichtungen die dort
leben und die dort beschäftigt sind und
die über 80-jährigen deswegen bitte ich
alle anderen bürgerinnen und bürger um
geduld um geduld und vernunft darum bat
auch der bürgermeister in hennef mario
dann gerade 31 jahre gewählt im november
2020 mitten in der korona krise
gemeinsam und solidarisch in hennef geht
das offenbar so am ersten januar
erhalten nicht nur die insassen dieser
seniorenresidenz ihre impfung sondern
auch der junge bürgermeister schon am
abend des ersten tages warum ließ sich
der 31-jährige bürgermeister impfen ein
interview lehnt die stadtverwaltung ab
also nachfrage auf der straße
kritiker behaupten dass sie ihre
privilegien als bürgermeister
missbraucht hätten was sagen sie dazu
so wie es gesagt habe wir sind als stadt
gebeten worden kurzfristig zu kommen
damit der impfstoff nicht verfällt er
hält sich nicht besonders lange geben
sind wir nachgekommen
warum wurden nicht die bewohner der
nahegelegenen seniorenwohnungen gefragt
die mediziner frank schmelting aus
hennef ärgert dass er hat gegen den
bürgermeister anzeige erstattet ich
denke es wäre schon mal gut wenn jemand
gesagt hätte es tut mir leid und eine
offizielle entschuldigung dafür das wäre
das 1 1 gewesen aber man steht dann doch
immer fest dass ich in so situation
jeder selbst der nächste ist und man
kümmert sich nicht um die leute die ein
die man sich eigentlich hätte kümmern
müssen was ja ein bürgermeister
eigentlich sollte auch sollte sich haben
die bürger kümmern erstmals und nicht in
erster linie um sich selber geimpft
wurde auch ex bürgermeister klaus pipke
heute drk-chef
halten sie es für rückblicken für
richtig vorzeitig geimpft worden zu sein
nein das ist bedauerlich war aber damals
der situation geschuldet und eben auch
dem druck im zeitlichen druck dass man
gesagt hat wir können diesen impfstoffen
irgendwo anders hin transportieren
mit der heutigen erkenntnissen wurde das
sicherlich nicht mehr machen
hamburg die städtische feuerwehr ist im
dauereinsatz beim kampf gegen das corona
virus laut im verordnung sollen gerade
notfallsanitäter und brand retter der
feuerwehr schnell geimpft werden
sie sind so heißt es wörtlich
beschäftigte mit hohem exposition risiko
wie intensivstationen notaufnahmen
rettungsdienste doch während über 2.200
von 2006 100 retter noch ob die impfung
warten ging es für andere schneller zum
beispiel für den chef der in einem
vorort gelegenen hamburger feuerwehr
akademie bernd herren kind ich finde das
erschreckend dass es dazu gekommen ist
dass die verwaltung und die
führungskräfte impfdosen erhalten haben
obwohl es durchaus möglich gewesen wäre
das rettungsdienstkräfte aus dem dienst
heraus zum elften gefahren wären beim
deutschen roten kreuz in hamburg harburg
wurde sogar die ehefrau des drk chefs
gleich mit geimpft mit uns reden will
niemand hier im regionalfernsehen der
feuerwehrsprecher mit
erklärungsversuchen wir haben einen
großen teil des personals abtelefoniert
wir haben auch viele gefunden die sich
bereit erklärt haben sich dort adhoc die
wir sagen impfen zu lassen
die besatzungen der rettungswagen
hingegen dürften während des dienstes
nicht geimpft werden entschied der
hamburger innensenator ein fehler sagt
die gewerkschaft grundsätzlich kann man
sagen dass es hier seitens der politik
ein unbedachtes 1
großes versagen gab wir fühlen uns vom
hamburger senat im stich gelassen weil
wissentlich nicht die richtigen
entscheidungen getroffen worden sind das
deutsche rote kreuz hat unterdessen
seinen hamburger chef mit sofortiger
wirkung von seinen aufgaben entbunden
aus krankheitsgründen heißt es
oberhausen auch geistliche zellen nicht
zur ersten impf kategorie außer sie
arbeiten in den heimen mit den alten und
schwachen zum beispiel hier im
seniorenheim guter hoffnung betrieben
von der neuapostolischen kirche
deutschland rainer storck spricht vor
allem von der kanzel
er ist eine art bischof für rund 600.000
gläubige per youtube gibt hoffnung durch
die zeit und hoffentlich bis bald einmal
wieder auch wenn es am anfang noch nicht
der fall sein kann aber dann mal mit
einem händedruck und etwas mehr als 15
meter alles gute der kirchenmann und
seine frau ließen sich anfang januar in
diesem oberhausen arnheim impfen wir
wollen wissen warum wurden nicht
stattdessen die bewohner der direkt
gegenüberliegenden seniorenwohnungen
geimpft
das büro der kirche auf unser klingeln
reagiert niemand dann treffen wir den
kirchenmann doch noch er hat uns gesehen
und angehalten
mir ist bewusst dass ich alles und damit
ausgelöst haben
und das tut mir sehr leid und
dafür möchte ich mich entschuldigen
vordrängeln beim impfen das gibt es
inzwischen deutschlandweit so zb in köln
wachtberg halle an der saale wittmund
und stendhal bagatelle sondern es geht
um eine ethische frage wer soll als
erster den schutz bekommen und da muss
es doch so sein dass derjenige die das
virus am meisten bedroht auch
tatsächlich als erstes in den blick
genommen wird